hello everyone
thank you very much for joining the
webcast today i
am miami fujita senior researcher of
national institute of radiological
sciences
and national institute for quantum and
radiological sciences and technology
in japan so today i'd like to talk about
the distinct metabolic profiling of
invading pancreatic pancreatic cancer
cells
so here is the outline for my talk today
there are four parts and the first part
is the background
and i'm going to explain about the
cancer cell invasion and transport
invasion assay
in the second part i'd like to show you
the inkeesite life so amazing
for identification of invading cancer
cells
and in the third part i'm going to show
you the metabolism analysis of
pancreatic invaded cells
and the last part is the conclusion
so here is the background during the
metastatic stage
cancer cells invade through the tumor
tissue and move into the surrounding
stroma
then introversate into blood vessels or
lymphatics
but as you can see in the diagram not
every cell
in vase and metastasize and
only those cells which have acquired an
invasive phenotype
can get into the surrounding stroma and
a metastasized
first understanding the characteristics
of
such a distinctive muscle population
especially
exhibiting the invasive phenotype as
compared with the non-invasive cell
population
is really fundamental for developing the
novel strategies to counter metastasis
so then how these cancer cells invade
and move through the surrounding stroma
the stromal environment of cancer cancer
in vivo
actually predominantly consists of
networks of type 1 collagen
like shown in this diagram
so from this diagram we can imagine that
the invading cancer cells
should have the ability to move through
such a complicated
extracellular metallics like collagen
networks
and the recent studies have shown that
invading cancer cells
actually use a variety of ways to move
through ecm networks
either by breaking the networks over the
purchases
moving through the ecm by forming the
leading edge at the
front and the lagging edge at the back
of the cell body
or by migrating through the ecm as
rounded bodies
forming a blep-like protrusions without
breaking the ecm
so again cancer cells exhibiting the
invasive phenotype should have the
special ability to move through ecm
and in order to study the
characteristics of the distinct tumor
cell population
that's specially exhibiting the invasive
phenotype
we first have to determine and figure
out which cell lines
have higher invasive potential
and this diagram shows the commonly used
experimental setups
for determining the tumor cell
invasiveness in vitro
which is called the transform in vision
assay
and this is a really popular asset model
to measure the invasiveness of cancer
cells
okay there are two media in the chambers
usually sedum free medium
is placed in the upper wall of the
transfer and the serum containing medium
is placed in the bottom wall
and then they are separated by polish
membrane on which a thin layer of
ecm is coated and as you can see in the
diagram
only the cells that have the invasive
phenotype
can move through ecm and reach the
underneath of the transfer membrane
so by staining those cells reached
underneath of the transfer membrane
we can count how many cells have
actually invaded through the ecm
from the total number of cells placed on
the upper wall of the transfer membrane
so that for example if we use
a several cancer cell lines and then
performed this
invasion assay for each line
independently
under the same as a condition we can
figure out which cell line is the most
invasive
and which the line is the least invasive
then we can choose the highest invasive
cell line
and then lowest invasive cell line and
then
use those sunlights to exam compare and
examine the factor affecting such
a different invasive ability
like examining the difference in
protease expressions
or difference in cytoskeletal regulation
and so on
and in our experiment using four human
pancreatic cancer cell lines
as you can see in this figure miyapaka
ii was the most
invasive cell line and then spc one was
the least invasive cell line among these
four cell lines so that we can choose we
can just
simply choose mere packaging and
spc once a line to compare the
differences
however interestingly
when we count the percent of invented
cells in this assay
we found that only a few percent of
cells
invaded through ecm like in the case of
merpaccatu
only about three percent of cells in the
whole culture
package were able to invade through ecm
and in the case of punk one only about
one percent of cells in the whole
cultured pancreas
were able to invade through exam within
24 hours
furthermore if we extended the time of
invasion assay for milpacatu or punk one
to be 48 or 72 hours instead of the 24
hours surprisingly
the percent of invaded salts were still
almost similar as the one counted
at 24 hours
so this is suggested that they might
have the distinct souls
especially exhibiting an invasive
phenotype
within the whole culture of mipatu or
punk wine
and actually it is an a really
interesting point
because miyapakatu or punk one is just
the identical cell line
which means that every cells in whole
carcinoma buckle two
or every cells in whole culture the punk
one
should have the same genetic background
but actually the data showed that only a
few percent of cells within the whole
cartilage mipatu or pancreas
were able to invade and
if there are such a distinct population
exhibiting an
invasive phenotype within the whole
cultured source of the same cell 9.
it would be interesting to collect these
distinct
invasive population and study the
characteristics
conferring the invasive phenotype with
comparing to the whole culture source
which have the same genetic background
metabolites consumed in different cell
lines for example
are thought to be affected by their
different genetic backgrounds
so that in order to determine the unique
uh metabolic profiling of invasive cells
collecting the distinct cell population
exhibiting the invasive phenotype
from the cells of the samsung line would
be intriguing
but is it really really true that
there are distinct cells especially
exhibiting an invasive phenotype
within whole cardiomyopathy or punk one
identify this we used the inside
lifestyle amazing system
and capture the movement of the distinct
invading population in real time
from within the incubator this would
minimize the disturbance to the source
and
allowed us to collect the kinetic
information
so we made a spheroid model using mere
packages or pancreas lines
and embedded in the metro and the cells
from the spheroid that embedded into the
material
were visualized over the inside lives or
amazing system
so here are the procedures cells were
seated into the 96 wall
auto low attachment plate with 100
microliter media
and floating formation was preceded by
the by incubating the plate
and in the co2 incubator for three days
then half of the media was carefully
removed
and 50 microliter of material with
concentration of six milligram per ml
protein
was poured into the interval so that the
final concentration of meteor was three
milligram per ml
and then this was solidified for two
hours in
co2 incubator after that
we carefully set the plate into the
inkside room
and capture the movies of the real time
amazing of the spelloid embedded in the
mage video
so this is the movie for me packaging
this is really a beautiful beautiful
movie
so you can see that actually only the
distinctive population within the
spheroid
can invade into the matrix gel
and also we can see that precise
information
of the way of my packaging invasion like
it forms elongated shape
to invade through majority
okay this second movie is for the punk
one
again you can see that only the
distinctive population within the split
can invade into the major show
and also we can see that in contrast to
the midpakatu
pangkwan actually formed the rounded
morphology to invade through the meteor
so from those movies it is clarified
that there are
distinct souls that especially
exhibiting
an invasive phenotype with endometrium
or
pancreas line so that it would be
interviewing to collect such an invasive
cell population
and then study the characteristics
conflicting this phenotype with
comparing
whole character cells
but then the every cell lines have those
distinct
invasive cell population
actually the answer is no
for example sf126 which is a human
glioma cell line
showed that there are no distinctive
population of
invasive cells and every cells the
spheroid
spheloid exhibited high invasiveness and
they all
move outward from the spheroid
so in the case of this kind of cell line
it is better not to perceive the
comparison study of
invasive versus non-invasive cell
population within
the cell line and we can say that
before proceeding this kind of study it
is better to
first perform the ink site life so
amazing
to make sure whether there are a
distinct in basic cell population
within the saw line that you are using
so that you can get the idea whether the
cell line that you are using is good for
the collecting
the distinct cell population or not
okay so this is the summary for the
second section
so using ink site live show amazing
system
we could visualize a beautiful movie of
the
actual invading cells from the spheroid
allowing us to identify the distinct
invading subpopulation from the cells
forming the spheroid
so in the next study we then analyzed
the unique characteristics conflicting
this
invasive phenotype with using the
pumpkins online
so this is the third part and in here
we performed the metabolism analysis of
pancreatic invaded cells
invasive cells must alternate their ecm
adhesion state
and display directional polarity and
modifying
their shapes so in contrast to the
non-invasive cells
it is hypothesized that the invasive
thoughts
need additional energy sources and
upregulation
to move such as amino acids nucleic acid
lipids or fatty acid
so from that we hypothesize that the
invasive soils may
show the unique features in the
metabolism
and as i mentioned in the previous slide
the metabolites consumed in the
different cell lines
are thought to be affected by their
different genetic background
but if we can collect the distinct
invasives of population from the
cells of the same cell line it would be
intriguing
for analyzing the metabolism especially
relevant to the invasive phenotype
because we don't have to care about the
difference in the genetic background
so in the study we used a pancreas
online and we collected the embedded
source as we identified using the ink
site
and to compare the metabolism
metabolomic profile
where the dose of whole culture the punk
one
the procedure is summarized here so we
first
confirmed that there are the distinct uh
invasive population within the whole
culture the punk one
with using the ink cited lifestyle
amazing system
then we performed the transform envision
assay with
pancoin and then collected the invented
cells reached underneath of the
transport membrane
with the treating cells with activities
for 30 minutes on
room temperature the control group
was a dish of cultural pumpkin cells
we used this as a control because
non-invasive sauce
in the top of the transport is stayed in
a cilan-free medium
for long time so that the medium
condition is different
from those of the embedded cells also
the embedded cells are only
only about one percent of the pumpkin
cells
so which means that ninety-nine percent
of the whole project cells
are non-invasive so we use
whole cartridge cells as the control
compared to the purified embedded cells
okay here are the result of our
metabolism analysis of the pancreatic
invasive cells
pc indicates that the metabolism profile
of the embedded souls was
very distinct from those of the whole
culture the pancreas
suggested that invasive cells have the
unique characteristics
in their metabolism
so this is the diagram shows uh the
differences in sugar metabolism for the
invasive
versus control cells the glycolytic
intermediate of the invaded pancreas
showed both a reduction and increase in
their concentrations
as compared with those of control
for example the level of glucose
6-phosphate
was reduced in the invasive cells
whereas
the downslim metabolite 3pc and pep
were both increased in addition
lactate levels were decreased in the
embedded source
suggesting that lactate fermentation was
reduced
in the embedded cells
recent studies have reported metabolic
changes during the proclamation of a
metastasis
like liu at all reported in jbc on 2010
that they compared the metabolism of the
normal
mouse mammal epithelial cell line to
those of
an isogenic series of cell lines which
is
exhibiting higher metastatic potential
and
vivo and in that report
they found that the glycolytic
intermediate especially 3pc and pep
and pyruvate were applicated in a
metastatic cell lines
as we observed in embedded pumpkin cells
in their study
so since invasiveness is one of the more
important
abilities to metastasizing cells
increasing levels of 3pt and pep may be
one of the unique metabolic futures
relevant to the invasive potential
so then what happened to the cells when
the three pc
and pep were upregulated
the specific accumulation of the 3pz and
pep
was observed when cells redirect
glycolytic carbon into the ceiling
and a glycine biosynthesis pathway
there is a biomedical evidence that the
phosphate group from pep
can be transferred to the histidine
residue
of pm where phosphorylated pgam is good
to
increase the ratio of 3pc2 to pc
and it makes the three pc and pep in
particular
are accumulated
and we have no yet to determine the
phosphorylation levels of pm
nor the activity of selling synthetics
but it would be interviewing to further
study whether the specific accumulation
of 3pc and the pep
observed in the invaded punk one were
the result of glucose flux directed
to the serene synthesis or not
okay this figure shows the tca cycle
for the tca cycle cyclic acid salicylic
acid
and malic acid were all reduced in the
cells with the invasive phenotype
first those metabolites may have been
utilized
more than they were produced in invasive
cells
or they were simply consumed less in the
invasive
cells
we also calculated the adrenal energy
charges
by using the formula indicated by
artikinson
at all so aec score of most
cells are known to range from 0.8 to
0.95
and if aec scores showed higher number
than this
it means that the down regulation of
energy metabolism
but if aec becomes lower number than
this
then it means that upregulation of
energy metabolism
and from our result ac score was
significantly lower in the
invasive cells compared with the whole
cardiac results
at 0.69 for the invaded cells and
0.82 for the whole chartered cells
respectively so that it is indicated
that the
invasive source consumed more atp than
the whole culture of the punk one
and accordingly this suggests that atp
generating pathways were stimulated in
the invaded cells
as it was indicated in the atkins
paper next
we calculated the indicator of arginine
metabolism
because there were the differences in
amino acid relating to the arginine
metabolism
and it is known that arginine is
metabolized to store
lymphinous but arginine also can be
metabolized to be on it and via
arginine so the ratio of steroid into
ornitine
can be the indicator of the consumption
of arginine by north versus alginates
and the amount was higher in the pumpkin
invaded cells
so that it is suggested that inverted
salts use
north more than alginates to metabolize
arginine
in addition the ratio of storaline to
arginine the indicator of noise activity
is also higher in invasive source
first this suggests that the invaded
cells are producing more nas than the
wcc
interestingly we have already reported
the role of
norse and pancreatic invasion in the
recent study
and the treatment of pancreas with the
nose inhibitor
diminish the invasiveness whereas
addition of anudona
increased their invasiveness so
it is suggested that higher activity of
north required in the embedded cells
caused the higher arginine conversion to
be stolen
and as a result the unique profile of
arginine metabolism was founded
in an invaded source
glutathione is one of the major factors
involved in anti-oxidation intracellular
glutathione
usually exists in at a reduced form gsh
and gsh is converted into the oxidized
form gssg
by stimulation with oxidative stress
so when cells are exposed to oxidative
stress
gssg are accumulated and the ratio of
gsh to
gssg will decrease
therefore the ratio of gsh to gssg
is a useful indicator of the oxidative
stress in the cells
and has been used as a as the index of
the intracellular state of stress
so in this study we also used gsh and
gssg concentration from the metabolism
analysis
and calculated their gsh
gssd ratio and actually we found
that the ratio of gsh to gssd
was significantly lower in the invented
cells compared with the whole cultural
function
so it suggests that the invasive cells
may
have experienced a higher obstacle of
stress than the whole cardiac
cells and interestingly
consistent with these findings pisconova
at
all also reported in nature on 2015
that metastatic melanoma cells showed
lower values for the ratio of gsh to
gssg
and then in that study they used tumor
bearing mice to compare the metabolites
of subcutaneous tumors with those of
circulating tumor cells
or lung metastasized cells and the
report is that
circulating two muscles and metastasized
cells
will experience the higher oxidative
stress
and showing lower gsh2 gssg ratio
than those observed in subcutaneous
tumors
so from that study they concluded that
melanoma cells which especially
resistance to oxidative stress
can successfully metastasize
so then how about in the embedded
pumpkin cells in our study
the greater production of oxidant result
in higher oxidative stress to the cells
which then impair cellular functions
so we next hypothesize that invaded
cells may be more resistance due to
of state of stress as piscono were found
in circulating tumor cells and
metastasized cells
first we next compare the sensitivity of
invaded
or whole cultured pancreas to oxidative
stress by performing the cell surviving
assay
with the addition of hdo2
and here is the result the graph shows
the survival
fractions of whole culture pancuan or
embedded pancreas
after exposure to h2o2 for 24 hours
the data shows that the surviving
fraction of embedded source for
450 micromolar or 500 micromolar of hdo2
exposure was significantly higher than
those of horchata
cells suggested that invaded pumpkin
cells were more resistant to oxidative
stress than the whole cartridge of
anchoring
furthermore we use the bso which is an
inhibitor of gsh biosynthesis
to see the effect of low gsh on the
invisible capacity of the pumpkin cells
treatment of pancreas also with the
2 3 or 4 micromole of bso for 24 hours
clearly reduced the intracellular gssh
content
in a dose-dependent manner however
it is also the toxic to the cells
so as you can see for 2 micromore of bso
the number of live cells were
drastically reduced
and when we performed the invasion acid
with the bso
interestingly although 0.3 micromodal
vso
or 1 micromolar vso diminished only 8
or 11 percent of cell numbers these
compounds
inhibited pancreas invasion more clearly
like 23 percent
or 46 percent reduction respectively
so it was indicating that the gsh
actually has a role
in pancreatic invasion
so um this is the summary of this whole
study
in this study we demonstrated that the
metabolic profiles of the invaded
pancreatic cells were distinct from
those of the whole culture the pancreas
and in contrast to the whole cultured
pancreas
the embedded sprung consoles were
characterized as the population over the
increased consumption of atp
with assurance activation of atp
generating pathways
and higher arginine utilization by north
and although they had higher oxidative
stress
the invading embedded cells were also
more resistant to it
with a greater survival upon exposure to
hdo2
and the reduction of intercellular of
gsh by bso
inhibited point invasiveness
so this is the conclusion of the
presentation
from this study again we found that the
unique metabolic characteristics for the
invasive pancreas population
using the inside life so amazing at
first
and from that information we could
develop a way to reduce the invasive
capacity of the cells
by using bso so
seeing is believing this cytosome system
can give
us a lot of important information about
a cancer cell invasion
and such methodology is readily
available for similar assessment of
invasive cell phenotypes
and this is the last slide showing
acknowledgement
uh great thanks to all colleagues from
advanced radiation biology research
program from national institute of
radiological sciences in japan
and consistency team from national
institute for quantum and radiological
sciences and technology in japan for
helpful discussions and advice and great
thanks to all colleagues from dr david a
wing club
from nih for providing expertise
discussions
and great thanks for amazing real-time
amazing system
inside the zoom from zeratorius company
and great thanks for metabolism analysis
from
human metabolism technologies in japan
so this is the end of the presentation
thank you very much for attending this
webcast
thank you for your presentation mayumi
it is now time for the q a uh to ask
mayumi a question just type it in where
it says type your question here and then
press
submit so our first question uh
miami and this one asks
can you describe in more detail
the method you use to collect the
invaded cells
from underneath of the um trans well
membrane
okay um thank you for the question
so first of all we have to use the
uh large size of transport inside which
just fits the six over plates
and then we caught us the transfer with
the material as
i mentioned in the slide and after the
solidification of a matrix gel
we seeded 1 million of pancreatic cells
on the upper wall of the transport
and performed the invasion acid for 24
hours
and then we wiped off the
natural gel with the cotton swab so that
the non-inverted salt stays on a major
gel
or the stays inside the materials were
all wiped off
and then then we wash the transfer with
pbs for two times
so um for washing uh we simply put
transfer into the other row of that
six water uh six well plate which is
filled with a
pbs engine um leave the transfer in
pbs for three minutes for two times
so we can watch the underneath of the
transfer with pbs for two times
and then after that um we put transport
into the new world of
fixed well plate so which is containing
uh the active
so that uh we left that transfer for 30
minutes at
room temperature inside the attitude and
then during that time
um cells attached underneath of the
transport membrane were detached from
the
transform membrane and then suspended in
a accurate solution
so that um by collecting the active
solution
we can finally collect the embedded
cells
and um also there are one another
important thing that um as you know that
invaded cells were only like a few
percent within the whole culture
themselves
in the case and procrastination so that
we have to use like uh
hundreds of transworld to collect the
invasive cells so that's the
really hard work part
excellent thanks next question
uh is from uh fernando
and this one asks um have you seen other
signs of higher oxidative
stress in inv cells versus the whole
cells
um can you see it again
yeah sure so fernando was asking um
whether you've seen
other signs of higher oxygen oxidative
stress in the inv cells
versus the whole all of the cells
okay um as i uh showed in
a in a slide i did um
the occupative stress experiments for
comparing invasive source and then
horchata cells and
uh with using the h2o2 addition of h202
and then actually um
invasive souls shows more resistance to
the
to the higher amount of h2o2 so
they are actually the the resistance to
the oxidative stress than the
whole culture cells
excellent thanks miami uh our next
question
uh and this one is from uh seema
and this one asks them how do you know
that the
inv cells have a similar
genetic landscape as the non-inv
cells and have you
then performed any next generation
sequencing analysis for these two
populations
okay uh this is uh thank you very much
this is a
really good question um okay uh so
at the first point i collected the
invasive souls from the
identical cell line penguin itself so
they are all punk on the part of the
palm consoles so
every cells or from panch1 so they
have the identical cell line identical
genetic background
so uh but i have not
uh actually determined
whether they are they have exactly the
same genetic background or not but
i think i also i'm interested in
um that invasive cells
might have the um i think that it's
interesting to study the possible
involvement of epigenetics in the
regulation of
invasive cells and then compared uh how
their differences in epigenetics
between engage with organoculture cells
excellent thanks miami uh our next
question
is from uh ahmed uh and he asks um
two questions so the first one is um
how was incu site useful to the six
well invasion assay and his next
question is
um did you try to grow any of these
invasive cells and characterize them
after a few passages
um so is it possible for you to answer
either of those two questions okay okay
uh
i actually don't uh get the idea of the
first x uh first questions like um
i do the invasion as they were the sixth
world uh
type of chance wall but it's it's it's
uh different from the
the inside lifestyle amazing so there
are the different
experiments so so before using the
before using the third line for invasion
transfer invasion essay i
actually performed the inside
life so amazing to make sure that
whether they have the
you know the distinct cell pop invasive
cell population or not and then after
that
we can use the six wall indigenous
transforming vision as the engine
collection we dip themselves
and for the second question um
what uh i forgot what was the second
question sorry
um so ahmed was wondering if you try to
grow
these um how did you try to grow the the
invasive cells and characterize them
after
a few passages okay okay uh i
actually uh grow the invasive salts
and then and perform the passages and
then
um i found that they're more 4g or
the the the doubling time everything was
similar to the
the horcultural pop consoles
excellent thanks mary uh our next
question
uh and this one asks them have you ever
tried this
um spheroid live cell imaging with other
cell lines other than panc one for
example
mia p a ca2 or sf126
and are there any differences in
invading population
between each of those cell lines okay
okay
uh yes uh we have used um
uh kasky uh which is the
cervical uh carcinomas online and then
mcf7
which is the breast cancer line and then
also we use
um as sw 480
for the colon cancers online and then um
we captured their images for three days
where the
lifestyle imaging with insight but uh
unfortunately they didn't show that uh
the distinct invasive souls population
in
that experiment so so far we confirmed
that uh mere packaging and pancreas have
the distinct invasive population
um and from that uh
information that we got from the from
the live cell amazing
like we uh got the information that
maybach
are invited toward the elongated shape
with higher speed than
punk one and then in contrast to the
pink one uh to the main pocket
point one used around decimal forces to
invade with a slower speed than my back
or two
and then um in the case of sf126 it did
not have such distinct
invaded population like uh maybach or
panchon did
but at the same time like um we got
interesting information that the
cells placed at the edge of the spheroid
actually move actively but not move
far apart from the steroids like my
bacteria or pancreas so they don't have
that they didn't have a
distinct population of invading cells
but still they were
like the edge of the cells were moving
but
uh not going um far up but move
far apart from the spirit so for the
answer of um are there any differences
in um
invading population between cell lines
um i think yes there are uh many
differences in invading population
between
its minds and then we can only figure
out
by um using the lifestyle
amazing weathering sites then we can get
a lot of
um interesting information and confirm
uh the uh whether they have the distinct
uh self-population for invasive
you know phenotype or not
excellent thanks mimi and just a quick
reminder to our live audience we still
have
some time to ask a question to ask one
all you need to do is type it in where
it says type your question here
and then press submit so our next
question
uh miami is from uh sharisha
and this one asks was genotype or
metabolism
metabolism metabolic metabolomic sorry
so let me just start again on that one
so was
genotype or metabolomic profiling or
even
further invasion assays applied to the
propagated cultured
invasive cells um
so can you say thank you yeah sure
so was either genotype
or metabolomic profiling uh applied to
the
propagated or cultured uh invasive cells
um i like that um i
um i haven't done the experiment for
genotyping so yeah i
don't have any answer for that sure
absolutely no worries maybe i'm sure
perhaps we can sort of follow up with
that
uh maybe offline um a bit later but
let's move on to our
next question uh and this one asks um
have you ever
tried any animal experiments to examine
the
metastatic ability with using these um
distinct pancreas invasive population
compared to the whole cultured pancreas
okay okay that's a good question to um
thank you very
much uh actually yes we have we are
really interested in uh
bringing the invasive souls to uh
to the animal experiment and then we
have done the
animal experiment as well but um i
didn't show
the data in this webcast because it is
just
unpublished data so but um anyway um
from that experiment um we have
clarified
that hong kong invasive population do
have
the higher metastatic ability to
especially to deliver comparing with the
whole culture department excellent
thanks mary um
our next question asks do
uh panc1 invaded cells relate to
um the cancer stem cell
and have you ever tried any experiments
studying
where the pancreas invaded cells have
stem cell properties or not
oh okay um that's a good question too
thank you very much
actually i have interested in that part
as well and then i
also hypothesized that maybe pancro and
invaded those have some really
relation to the cancer stem cells so i
actually have done some experiments to
figure out whether
like invasive cells have cancer stem
cell collectors or not
and then it's all unpublished data so
i haven't shown any of the data on my
webcast slide but um
i can say that like uh pancan embedded
cells
did have did have um some of the stem
cell properties but
not for everything like um like um many
uh for example many papers have
reported that like cd44 is
the one of the cancer stem cell marker
for pancreatic cancer
but there were not uh significant
differences
in cd4 explanation between uh
soils and whole cultured park one but
the uh
on the other hand um the ability of
spheroidogenesis
were significantly high in invasive
source
so some of the data issues that invasive
cells have
cancer cell property but uh some of the
data shows
it's negative so it is still for me it
is still unknown
whether um invasive cells are the
cancers themselves or not
so i made further experiments for that
excellent thanks mary and our next
question
asks them you mentioned that um pac-1
invaded cells exhibit resistance uh to
oxidize
stress do those cells show resistance
to anti-cancer drugs or to radiation as
well
oh oh okay um i happen haven't tried
the experiment to see the uh the
response to the
anti-cancer drugs but i have done to
um see the difference in radio
sensitivity and then um
actually um pumpkin invaded cells are
more
resistant to the to some of the
radiation types than the whole cultural
background so
at least i think to some types of
radiation
invasive cells are more resistance and
so
they might have risk to
survive more after such kind of
radiotherapy or so from this
point of view that is uh really i think
that uh it is important to
study and to understand the
characteristics of
such uh invasive cell population and
figure out how to
block those cells effectively
thank you